Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to West of Loathing! Now
It seems, according to you guys, that it's a very very bad idea like the worst idea
I could possibly have so
unbelievably bad
idea to take this goblet for some unknown
reason. Nobody could give me a straight answer as to what it goddamn did
So I'm going to assume that
taking it is going to be bad and
destroying it is probably good, but you know I
... It's like the hat situation where I gotta have to you know. It's a blood filled goblet!
What, am I not gonna take that with me. How am I gonna resist that when I could! You know,
There's no save mechanic in this game. It's all, like, continuously save, so no matter what I do
I can't save and go back if I wanted to go back, I'd have to play through it again, So imma
take this goddamn goblet. I can y'all screaming, "NOOO!"
And I can hear you also screaming, "YESSS!"
But I'm gonna take it. Alright. A chill runs down your spine as you touch the goblet
Uwh, I stuck my hand into many of spittoons, but this gets my blood going
There's a goblet of blood from a cursed altar in a spooky secret basement room. It's probably safe and fine and good
Hey, what is that? Oh it's my 'sorting by ordered'. Oh, what's a smoking Chrysanthemum? I don't need that
Alright, well, I took it. Didn't seem to do a lot. Maybe I gotta take it up to a
Lady here. The doll.
Heyyyy!
How's it going? My tea! We can *laughs*
Finish our tea party right now. I
don't know if I want to do this, but sure, why not. You carefully pour the blood from the goblet into Grace's mouth?
Grace leaps up litter box, laughing maniacally, climbs the ranch house's ruined chimney.
She turns towards you. See you soon! She leaps to the ground, mind the house, and scampers off to the northwest
That's probably
fine
That's probably fine *laughs*
Well, my work here is done. To the northwest, you say? To the northwest is somewhere up there.
Let's see if I can wander around and maybe I'll find
Shaggy Dog cave, oh.
That's not where I wanted to go but ok I guess we're going there right now. Oh
God, I don't have foraging. Hey, how's it going there? What's up? Oh, oh Gary knowing a thing to see oh?
Yeah, what is it? A gigantic, poop!
What? Taller than Gary! You discovered a new map location the big apple. Ok. Alright then thanks for the reminder.
I'll see you around Gary; I got to go over here and explore see if there's anything good to see
Alrighty then.
Hello. Oh! Many signs, many words! If Gary could read in human, so many words would reading here! What they say?
Guess I'll find out, ok.
There's a plaque bolted to the cave wall. Read it. A record of the events of the Expedition To And Into Shaggy Dog Cave, as
recorded by Jim Plaquewright.
Alright.
Let me slide over to the next one.
Alright. Having acquired through various and sundry means, a story which is interesting in its own right, but better safer another time,
A map purporting to lead to a large cache of jewels and ingots
of precious metals hidden by the infamous highwayman and train robber Black Coal, Jr. in the years before The Cows Came Home
I, Jim Plaquewright, along with three compatriots -- these being Nathaniel Wyman, Cyrus Howard, and Douglas Watts --
Set out to find Shaggy Dog cave and the aforementioned treasure. Okay?
What about that? Our equipment and provisions consisted of: one cart, and a horse to pull it, four additional horses to be ridden, two shovels,
a spade, and a mining pack; a large coil rope; one large basket of eggs, as well as an assortment of other trail provisions and cookware, my
own collection of blank plaques and engraving tools;
one large and shaggy dog; and a buttfor. Don't ask me what a buttfor is.
What's a buttfor?
After traveling for two and a half days to the south and east, we arrived at a small town of Dirtwater, the largest settlement
in the vicinity of Shaggy Dog Cave.
Leaving the local dog to watch the horses, the four of us entered the local saloon and each ordered a beer -- except
for Cy, who was satisfied with water. Alrighty then, better
Be have a good bath. The barman provided our drinks as requested,
And withdrew a small wooden box underneath the bar asking us if we care to witness something real interesting.
Considering that we had still it quite a few hours left to travel
We politely declined and asked him if he knew the way to Shaggy Dog Cave. He replied that he would never been there personally
But gave us rough directions which correlated nicely with the notes on our map.
Okay
and
Upon leaving the saloon we discovered or just made that some unknown villain tampered with our wagon.
Fortunately, the only supplies missing were the buttfor and the
entire basket of eggs, apart from one that dug it concealed within a pocket for safekeeping. We also discovered that the dog and
Absconded with one of the horses
Forcing Nate and Cy -- after drawing of lots -- to share. After acquiring a barrel of fresh water for the trip, as well as a replacement buttfor,
We headed out into the open desert. The sun shone down mercilessly up on us, though
we took some solace in the fact that it would've been far more intolerable had we took this expedition in the summer rather than in the month of
November. In order to pass the time on the trip and resist becoming dazed from the hear and susceptible to desert mirages, we exchanged stories of
Our youth, which I will not be retail here for reasons of length. Whew boy.
However, I will relate to you three odd occurrences that happened to us during our trek through the desert.
The first was two or three hours out of Dirtwater, when Nate noticed a glint of sunlight upon a metal
object partially buried in the sand. This was revealed to be a brass oil lamp
of foreign design and manufacture, which fortuitously still contained a quantity of oil.
Deciding this might come in handy, we stashed it in the wagon with our other tools. Ughhhh.
Our next encounter was with a nomadic gobin tribesman
Who we discovered spoke excellent English
It enquired as to our destination, and we replied that we were looking for Shaggy Dog Cave, though we did not disclose the reason
For our journey. The goblin confirmed that we were heading on the correct course, and mentioned only a short time earlier witnessed a large and shaggy dog riding a horse in the same direction.
We all agreed that this was an unusual sight indeed, and continued on our way. Some time later we encountered a large adobe hut, occupied by two identical seeming
white beards. *From here on out, Mark's speech becomes fast fowarded too fast to make out any proper words*
ughhhhhhhhhhhh
*From here on out, Mark's speech becomes fast fowarded too fast to make out any proper words*
Eughuhhhhh
It's a troll. This is a troll cave
*From here on out, Mark's speech becomes fast fowarded too fast to make out any proper words*
Eugh, eugh eugh
FUUUUUUUCK YOUUUUU JIM!
It's hole. A completely empty one. There was no point in any of this
What's a buttfor? I'm Gonna ride my lamp back
They was no
point in any of that!
I'm just Gonna Ride
I'm gonna Sail on the Sandy Seas of the interior of this goddamn cave.
Oh my God, how much did I just read? How much of my life did I just waste there that I could have been doing anything?
How will this moment in this cave rob me from some precious memory I'll never know in my future. Oh
The aristocrats. Old goblin joke. Ughhhh
There was no pointed any of that. *pitiful laughter*
Okay
McKittrick store, where's McKittrick store. Oh boy. Where am I going?
McKittrick Store. Cavern Canyon?
Is that where we're supposed to go?
Where's McKittrick's? Oh, oh, I got a go to it ah
Okay, well this is to the northwest. Let me go to Cavern Canyon, see if anything's up there. You encounter an overturned wagon.
Alright invent. Oooh advance cow punching!
I like me advanced cow punchin'. Can I get some of that I get some of that?
Let's see I can get menacing moo, a skill reduces muscle, Bull stomp small amount of damage, ever-vigilant
Increases your maximum ap by 2. I'm gonna get that one that good.
ooh
Then you shoot the book into pieces because you don't trust it or anything else anymore. *laughs*
The book had it coming. It did indeed. It did indeed. Hey, what does the sign say? That one? It says "DANGER!
SPIDER!"
Danger spider? Okay. Good luck to you. Gary is to staying here for the horse. Alright. Well that's..
Maybe extra view? Pry off the boards! Those boards can't hide from your prying eyes or your prying crowbar
Oh, I wish I had to get in the coffee cactus. So what's with all these caves. I'm gonna go on the one
I just pried, ooh
Danger spider
Door has like 15 Dead Bolts on it
the note tacked to it says -
Please don't open this door unless you want to get Eaten by a giant spider
Even then don't open it because the rest of us don't want to get eaten by a spider
It isn't even signed so you can hardly be expected to take it seriously
Here we go. The tunner behind this opening goes straight up. There's no way to get through it unless you're a huge spider.
Well, I guess I shouldn't have opened that door then
Whoops my bad. Oh, what's this then?Oh hideout cave. You can see the gang. Ahhh
Maybe if you had more legs, you'd be able to pick your way through. Oh! Well...
Maybe I shouldn't worry about the goddamn spider then!
Ow.
Well, then what's that? Hmm. The bones make you pretty reluctant to investigate this. Ho ho ho ~
Medicine. Alright I got laudanum.
You said you hear a sudden chittering coming from the big hole behind you. Huh that's peculiar
You must have a death wish sitting this close to that thing. Eh, not really!
Should leave right now before that spider eats you. I don't know about that. Well look over here
Oh, yeehaw! I gotta
leave
Well, that was bad. No way are you going back in there?
I don't know. kind of want to go back in there. Can I go back in there?
I guess you could only get one thing out of that. You hear a horrible skittering noise. Followed by a scream followed by more horrible skittering noises.
Followed by more screams followed by some wrapping noises followed by some muffled screams
Then there's more skittering than silence. I'm Gonna go inside
Hey, how's it going in here guys? What's up? How's it going. The gang has been prepped for spider consumption?
Arrest them? *laughs*
Don't do anything just yet. Let me see this. Hang on. Let me see what's going on here. Doodlie doo do do. Danger kitchen?
Danger bar? *laughs*
What's in the danger bar? Huh?
It looks like this place needs a new bartender. What's this? Oh I got a jaw harp.
Maybe they killed him for playing the jaw harp too much, okay? All right. Well all these bottles are empty
No point of being here.
What's in the danger kitchen? Oh hi! Hello? What are you doing?
The poor chef has chained to the wall, his eyes widened as you approach. Hey, you're not one of them!
Are you here to rescue me?
Sure! Well, thank goodness. He thrust his hand into yours and shakes vigorously. I'm Doug! Mumflr. How do you do, Doug? Well,
I've been chained up in this dank cave for weeks cooking for those stripy
Tatted idiots. Sounds awful. You wanna hear the worst part?
There's a perfectly good oven eight feet to my right and the shelf of perfectly good ingredients eight feet to my left
How's that the worst part? Chain is only four feet long. It's rough. I know right? There
I was fresh out of culinary school with a million meat ideas in my head and now here
I am four feet shy my dreams cooking the same pot of soup over and over again
What million meat idea? You, uh, you promise not to steal my idea, right?
I promise. Okay then. It's a new kind of sandwich or maybe a taco
It's still revolutionary
And I'm not quite sure how it fits in the whole hand food taxonomy to be honest. Anyway in the middle of it
There's a sausage, but it sauce is made from the cheapest possible parts of a pig, ground-up
So finely you can't identify them anymore. Okay... And it served in a long split role
Which soaks up the grease so you can't tell how fatty the sausage is?
The best part? The name. You ready to hear the name? Sure. I call it the hot doug.
What do you think?
About The Hot Mumflr instead? Don't be ridiculous! Hot Mumflr? What does that even mean?
Ridiculous. Hey, there's no need to be mean about it.
Not that any of this matters anymore. Even if I did get off this chain
There's no point in hanging around this empty cave making hot dougs just for myself.
I don't even like the taste of them! You can set up shop in Dirtwater.
Brilliant! You're a genius, Mumflr! Hot Dougs for sale, all day everyday! I'll make a mint! Say, there's an idea.
What if I added mint to the sausage mixture?
He open breaks his chains; he leaves the cave hauling the oven and a shelf of ingredients muttering to himself about new sausage recipes
Well alright then
Too bad about that. I guess we're all done here. Hey guys what's going on here? I'll arrest them. Maybe
sure
You stack the cocoons on the back of your horse, except for one which
Gary offers to drag, and then head back to Dirtwater Jail.
Is that the Stripey Hat gang? What happen to them? They had a run in with a giant spider. A giant spider of justice.
Fortunately, the reward is for results rather than
explanations. Groovy!
I guess they're just gonna be like that. Just wanted to say hi. Hello. Alright I'm gonna head back now.
I got work to do in that canyon. Oh, gotta travel never mind. You find a wrecked bank stagecoach- Ooh!
I'll pick it open. Hey! That's a good amount of meat! I like that meat.
that's good meat right there. Ok lets see if the spiders still there. No? Aww
Spiders still there? Then what's this cave all about then? What's all this then huh.
This bullshit. This is bullshit. Alright alright. Well if it's bullshit, then we're gonna get out here.
Buttonwillow's store. Probably fine. You see a streak of fire blasts across the sky. Alright.
That's a lot of meat. That is a lot of meat
How did I get so much meat? alright, I'm gonna do some shopping you need anything trail mix? no, thanking
you. Gary is good and well.
Thanks, okay, then. Ow ow fricken ow
Hellooo!
At first you're excited because you think this barrel is full of pickles, but they turn out to be novelty rubber pickles
Huh, alright. The woman behind the counter stares at you with a huge grin on her face
Alright, what do you got? Oh shroom grow? Ah, I could always use more shroom grow
Everything else here? Mind
your meat. This book is a guide to making the most of your meat by getting the best possible deal and every single thing you buy
Gives me dickerin'! I can afford that! I want dickerin'! Oh god
yes! I've been looking for dickerin'. Mind your meat!
You read the book from cover to cover and learn among other things that its cover price is way too high. Well damn it!
Alright. After you're done reading it you use your newfound skills to pawn it off on a wide eyed room for about 60 meat
Done and done alright, okay, alright
Well then, how much can I sell anything for? Nothing at all. Alright, I know
Just sell. This is a certificate entitling the bearer to 13 shares of Standard Footwear Company, a company based in Topeka
Just sell it. Alright, okay. We'll do it. Alright alright.
I'm outta here, baby. All out here in my weird way that I am is out of here
Alright, so let me wander a bit more. There's got to be something else here right? I don't know where that doll went. You...
Lettering.. the Dave yard?
I'll go the dave yard. Oh!
That where the doll went? Seems like it might be where the doll went, hmm. Here lies Dave B.
Died with his boots on but not his pants. Ah a man after my own heart
This is sure enough you dig up the grave just to check the veracity of the epitaph sure enough boots
But no pants. Brown boots. Alright. I got brown boots. What does that do to me maximum ap? Hell
yeah! Also, I probably should... I should... I should
do something about this. Still got that gobble of the blood which is nice, I guess?
This, uh,
grits.
Alright
Okay that uh-huh
You eat the grits. It reminds me of breakfast back home and give you a real hominy feeling uh-huh okay?
Cuz it's made of goat milk extracted from plump utters. Oh
Plum pudding.
Great. I'm Gonna eat that
You eat to pudding even though you haven't eaten your meat
No dark Sarcasm here. Alright. Okay. That's weird. Okay here we go. The remains look pretty restless put them down for good
Alright, what do you got for me?
No Gary, no! I gotta meat up, bro!
I wanna poison shoot you, cause I can.
Bang get some stench damage, apparently.
Hey, oh my god. Gary you're too strong. Skull chips, gold tooth. Your life; Dave C, went down in a
theater. Your life's Dave J, ra-pa-pa-pow.
Let's see... I'll put you down
Eh, oh, you guys are just big old babies. I'm not even gonna need to muscle up for you
We're just gonna attack you good, and you're gonna be dead. Oh no, he gone.
Okay, Skeleton bone
Doodlie do dee doo. Ooh.
Your lives Dave L. Died of a heart attack. Oh, that's why it's the dave yard! It's a graveyard full of Daves.
See you in negative 36 years.
Your life's Dave G. He looked to the sky to save him, but even the sky can't save a feller from, like, 40 angry bears.
Looks like the Gravedigger left his lunch box here
Oh boy, free lunch! Vienna blood sausages, thermos of spiked coffee, and they said there was no such thing! ah
I guess that's good uh
Vienna blood sausages, I'll leave them. Oh yeah, you can't eat that because you're already too full level up your grit to increase your appetite
All right, these bones are jumping around to the beat of the dickens. It
Be the dicken's! We're jumping around a beat the dickens basically. Beat the dicken's up.
I'll beat the dickens outta ya. Oh?
Yeah, you don't get most spooky damage to me. I'm too tough for you. I'm legitimately too tough for anybody here. Oh
Skeleton Bones
What else we got here before I go in there? Dave D. The truth was out there.
It killed him. Dave G. Murdered by a different feller named Dave G.
Pile of bones that isn't moving around for a change. Dig through it. Oh, I got a skull with an odd tag on it
Alright, what does that mean?
That's the
Intercemetary loan on one side and some notes on the other
Tag on the skull is a serial number and says it was borrowed from the submission catacombs on
February 19 ,1886. Jesus, this is really late! The back of the tag is catacombs address. Old missions skulls! Check him out.
Alright, okay glue later.
Hello
Anybody in here? Anybody at all? Hello. Oh, it's one of those things they have in mausoleums
You know it's one of those big marble things full of drawers full of skeletons
Oh, hope I don't open a whole bunch of them. I'm gonna open a whole bunch now
Gary no! Okay, it's fine.
Alright, then I'm gonna might actually be a bit of a bit of a scuffle here, but a muscle-up
Hit you real good oh whump. Oh, you're dead. Oh, no, all right
Hit you. Hi-yah, style. Yeah, all right. You're almost dead. Yeah
Alright, got that easy-peasy
Is that just is that just a way to farm some fights? That's pretty convenient. Oh
This looks bad. Drawn on the ground with red chalk. Ah.
Pile of mostly burned rags that maybe used to be a person. Great.
Gore splattered scroll, human ashes, road receipt: Great! Why?
What is this?
150 black ropes? It's time we start Gathering clues about the whole
Perambulating dead situation that's going on around these parts
You grab a notebook and paper clip the receipt to the first page got a necromancer of germinal I should check that out
Alright.
You help your knight, er,  your necromancer journal and examine the information you've collected so far.
You found a receipt for delivery of robes. Looking at it more closely you see there's a surcharge for delivery to Boulder pass
That means the necromancers layer is definitely west of the mountains. Good to know.
Progress! Alrighty then.
What else I got? Gore splatter scroll, great
You scrape the largest of the giblets off of the scroll and read it. It says to take a pile of human ashes and spread them around in the
shape of a person inside a red rock ritual circle, then sprinkle them with star dust and placed a mostly perfect or better glass sphere
where the heart should be. Anyway, that's the gist of it. The actual text has a lot mroe "thee"s and "thou"s and such as like that.
Plus there's a weird a bit of weird gibberish you're supposed to say out loud while you're doing it, okay. Good to know
great
All right, it's the cremated ashes remains of a person someday they'll refer to these as cremains, but you will not approve oh
Leave them alone for now. Maybe I should scatter them or somewhere a little bit better. Oh perform the ritual oh
I don't eat glass spheres. Oh, okay, all right
I don't even know if I have stardust but they're okay all right, whatever all right, so apparently that little girl laying here
Let's Wander a bit more
Skeleton approach you turn that jittery stop motion-y way that skeletons do judging by a tad it appears to be the skeleton of a
beanslinger. You remember the classic saying: Old beanslingers die like normal people, but sometimes they keep walking around and casting spells at you afterwards.
Okay
Ow!
All right, well I got bean stain pants. I don't know what that means, but I got him. Ooh snake pit mine
That's a new one. Ooh what's this? It's an exposed meat vein.
That sounds horribly like a vagina
Oh, a digging hole! Much quite big, much a lot of digging must be!
Do goblins mind for metal? Some! Not much not like human digging it all up.
But metal is full of many uses. Hitting with hammer making better hammer. Sure, okay, alright. Look at mining equipment
You have no idea what any of it does. Ask Gary to explain it to you. Hey, how does this work? Oh?
Oh, no, no gary doesn't knowing that
Thank you, Gary
Gary you know what this? There's? No, okay? Alright. How about this one Gary? Gary? No? Ok. Alright then.
I'll just be on my way.
Alright, wish I had foraging, but I don't.
Hello. By the loose boards? Ok.
Snake coiled up in a little hole. Pull it and punch it.
Do I have to?
Again it's meat, great!
Snakes in this smoking hole. This is smoking snake uh uh cash mining supplies. Alright well got those.
Hmm, alright.
Got a pickaxe. Yeah, that's good. Maybe I can use it on - Oh!
Wow, that was horrible. I'm um. I'm gonna beat the shit out of these snake eggs, whoo
Is there any way I can hit all of them?Probably not. This seems like really mean to just kind of beat up these eggs
Yeah I'll hit 'em.
This seems... this seems bad. Oh! Oh,
Okay, I get it now. They were always bad. I was just doing doing him a favor. That's what I was doing
Oh, no, Gary your son died. What are you gonna do? Oh nothing, ok. Alright. Oh.
Wait, I forgot about my varmint skinning knife. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait, wait wait
Yeah, cuz I want the skins of the beasts. Alright, you smoking snake, oh.
Ow, uh, eh, uh
Imma poison you. Guess there was no point cuz you're about to die.
Alright, okay, all done, here.
Well that was productive
and I'm a horse apparently. Well at least take out a pickaxe which is going to be useful in the future I can only imagine.
What else we got? Woah! I can use my cow punching ability! I'm gonna get beefy for you because you need to get beefed!
Blam!
Abhayam point whoa, okay, wow that wasn't a lot of damage. How about some stance? Oh, no.
Tainted milk.
Don't know if I want that milk, but I got extra thick leather! Which is nice.
Alright where else can we go? Railroad Camp, Old Mission...
Boobidy boobidy boobidy boobidoo. Cause it's always possible the doll went beyond the mountains.
And that's probably something that's very important to understand
But I'm gonna go to Fort Cowardice first just to see how that goes. Hundred yards away solitary, Skeleton
I'm gonna beat the shit out of it. Oh
I'm Gonna get VP
Alright, arriving - Ooh! Hey
How's it going.
Hmm this fort quite very quiet beam. I thought goblins hear that sound a band it might as well. Have a look okay?
Just like the old saying goes when life give you cannons makes make cannonade.
Whewph, that was a bad one. Ok, let's see. Hey! Hey! Hey! Goblins! Goblins here somewhere! Really?
How can you tell? How you can't? Uh, well, I'll let you know if I find any, I suppose.
Climb up the watchtower and take a look around. Nice view up here!
Oh!
Butterfield Ranch! Oh!
That's nice. Someone going here? Any goblins in there? I heard that there might have been goblins here. They're incredibly boring
No, I really want the details. You find one. You read Becky Smith secretary. Grade..
Satisfied! Another?
You find one. Major
Ezra wolf. Another. Another. Another. Another. Another. Another. Another. Now you're just looking at the same ones
you've read before. What is wrong with you? I can't get enough!
These are good
These are good. Oh, I love them! All these are good.
Alright, well, thought there would be some kind of reward for this. I don't know why I thought that but I thought it, okay.
Reception desk and most appropriate thing for it to receive would it be a free trip to the dump? Ooh?
Food? Oh.
Military-Grade whiskey, I don't know what that means. Cupboard, spice rack. Saltpeter? I got that saltpeter that the guy wanted
Well, I don't know what that means for me here. I'm out of needles, but what else do I have in here?
I've got a whole bunch of shit, don't I. Oh I need to spend my exp!
Oh shit, I've got so much Exp. Well. I need more glamour and gumption. That's definitely...
whoof
That. Yep, ok. How about some of the
Goodie good for me. I'll get another needle and I'll come back here for that one. That's all wait
This is exactly what I was just in Goblin
Whoo you hear the sound of several goblins storing inside the stent not bothering let them sleep, okay, all right then geez wow
Hello
Todd is soaked with blood great based on the papers an anatomical diagram scattered across its surface
You're getting to this fort that's belonging to the Fort Cowardice is nurse
Look at the papers papers are mostly just boring medical records Dental Dagger rule tapes
Lamentations that antibiotics haven't been discovered yet that kind of thing hey. What's this looks like it might be important marching orders
Oh, they're just a bunch of disgusting drawings of sliced open bodies, but I did get marching orders. What does that mean?
Marge back east just as fast as you live the liver lily livered little yellow-bellied feet can go.you damnable towers
Right then they went to fort all dead
Treacherous territory up there a feller ought to be careful. They went to all dead I
Love that. I love that
You're the fort all dead
Sign says toilet in Goblin which makes it seem pretty likely that Goblin geezers 10:00 at the toilet?
No, where are you going in there wait? No, I want to go in there
oh
I want to go in there yikes this Mishap. Definitely got somebody fired
An unusually sized cannonball you got a dem I culverin Cannon
Oh, why did I pick that up no damn? I less know Demi Moore? Oh, I get it. That's funny. All right
I'ma come to force my way over here. Well. Why can't we wake up the goddamn Goblin?
Why can't we wake up the Goblins I?
Guess I got to pick that lock don't I I don't have one I can go buy some can't I?
Let me go back to town doodlee. Do you got to go to the Mercantile? Hey you got any uh picking locks?
No, you don't you don't do you I'll buy this book off. Yeah, but you don't do you
Even though I got the dickering ability all right thick-skinned
Armor Bull stomp a maker. Oh, oh
Hell yeah, oh, I want the haymaker
I want to be swinging my haymakers around oh witch away, so I could be smacking cows in their goddamn face
Perfect okay, so that's good. I
Don't think I have any letters would I nope okay? All right then so I think that's going to do it for this episode
Thank you everybody- Ooh hot dog! Hot doug man! Hot doug. Howdy doug! Well if it isnt my saviour good ol mumflr. Howdy yourself. The sign outside. Yeah
I had to change the name I tried to file a trademark and it turns out. There's already something called a hot dog
What is it? trust me. You don't want to know. I wish I didn't know. Anyway, a single letter removed, and I'm in business
He gestures at the menu behind the wall alright
I'll buy uh
Buy a nice Jumbo Dog
Look a thick strurdy hot dog for a big Sturdy Cowboy
Because hot dog it has been embellished with a zesty thought don't get too excited though
It's the zesty sauce is just regular old mustard
This is exactly enough sausage in exactly enough bun to qualify as a hot dog it is perfectly efficient all right
I'll take this big one to pick it. I don't know if I can eat it it's my gumption enough ah
my grits not enough, ooh
Maybe I can get it all right now. I
Know I can eat that hot dog hell. Yeah get it in me what?
I'm just uh oh you sack with you anyway, all right. That's enough for that this episode
Thank you everybody so much for watching I'm doing the heck out of this hope you are too, so let me know
What do you think down the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video